[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
when we talk about whatever we wanted
today we have sinned thank you for
having me back thank you I appreciate it
also we have our very first sponsor
sponsor who is it so this episode is
brought to us by brought to you guys by
Roman and they are a EB company which is
erectile dysfunction and 52% of men over
40 experienced erectile dysfunction at
some point wow you guys have experienced
with Edie
yeah right now say right well oh you had
oh yeah you did it someone over 40 50
all of them yeah really
every time they all need it sighs what
were they circumcised one was it it was
that to do it there's nothing to do I've
heard that it did really cuz like the
nerves well anyways I work from our
sponsor well anyways but what sucks
about is that 75 percent of those guys
don't go seek treatment and there could
be there's a stigma it's it's a hassle
but that's why Roman made are really
easy to chat with a doctor online so you
can do from the comfort and privacy of
your own home please go to the online
get Roman comm / OTR which stands for
off the record you can complete an
online visit and if your doctor decides
that treatment would be appropriate they
can prescribe genuine medication that
can be delivered and discreet packaging
right to your door with free two-day
shipping get Roman comm / OTR for free
online visit and free two-day shipping
thank you hey hey said all these guys
let's talk about you yeah that God that
did that Anya yeah so sorry putting it I
love you ru victim-blaming them because
they have IDI no I am NOT I think it's
awesome like here you go I want a
prescription to viagra so that way I
have it just like off hand in case they
need it
Oh your work for me actually had some
shift
I won't shift but there's this guy I
hooked up with and he didn't need it he
was like younger but he's like I don't
know what this is but like the guys in
their 20s they're like oh I can't get
harder the condom like that's your
[ __ ] fault whatever the [ __ ] wrong
they're lying to look ridiculous I mean
this is why I don't have sex with guys
in their 20s um so anyway I had my gays
they like put viagra in an envelope and
taped it to their door and they gave it
to him and he picked it up is that right
today you're going to have drugs dealers
huh yeah I know I was like damn I need
my own prescription or something so that
way I have it in case guys try to use
that excuse you don't worry about that
yeah I know
make sure that you didn't hate victims
no I see okay yeah I've never had sex
with the dude that didn't need it and
then he took it and what happened is
that something is just like never ending
that's what causes a UTI like you need
to like take a break yes wait I thought
all girls want the neverending sex stuff
no some that we need a break we need to
recharge okay just that's for people out
there that's for people that like porn
yeah okay well that like porn they watch
porn they think that's what they have to
do feel good yeah fifty-two minutes is
too long bro it is a long time I listen
to a book recently and it was so weird
about all these creepy [ __ ] fetishes
they are out there like I didn't know
half of this [ __ ] out there like existed
like crazy [ __ ] like pooping on people
eating caca that's pretty weird I know
that exists for talkin when the foot
yeah when the foots is like this do you
Monty's did that actually your dick
energy do I love her she did the the
know the good job what do you mean she
did it with the shoe well that's what
were the foot like she steps on him no
like his shoe goes into her [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] she goes into her [ __ ] that hurt I
don't know I've never done it yeah you
gettin [ __ ] with this soon yeah you get
down like that right anyways it like the
stiletto is it like the thick ass heel
one it's like like a stripper shoe I
hope they wash their feet I think a
dildos on the end of it hope they used
it like a moist shout towel or something
on it I hope he bought a new pair of
shoes for it though they should hey wait
so there's like it's about the one that
she walked in with oh great I want to
know I want to rise I want to be
surprised because I'm not surprised
anymore with porn I know I know surprise
me come on surprise all right yo dildo
heel but it's like wobbly right okay so
balloons amputees bandages there's this
whole like Japanese broken dolls like
you get like a full-body cast it's like
kind of like weird is the thing body
modification
like body body parts hey what's that one
neck navel thighs butt oh I thought it
was like getting a fin or something with
that know like like modifying your body
to like having like kangaroo feet or
something those furries we all know
furries expert peers things into furries
um clowns that's a big one no way people
are trolling really weird you like brush
it you know people are like kind of like
step on this
Oh step on my dick [ __ ] yeah
um adult diapers you know guys women's
great enemas I like how it looked at yet
there's no reason for that
oh yeah I don't think that you're hoping
that was more behind some fantasy
creatures fad fetishes which is really
strange some men love to feed be like
what do you mean like feed a pizza to
their partner yeah like like me that's
what moms were before like a fetish
thing dude I believe that I think ASMR -
there's some weirdos there but but I
have a friend who's a bigger chick and
she said that she has to be wary when
she's going on dates because some guys
like to just keep ordering food for her
to eat and yeah when I was in fifth
grade oh that's then when I was in fifth
grade I was riding my bike around the
neighborhood and I saw a page out of a
like a playboy kind of cut out and I
lifted it up and it was as obese lady
write an ad said find a crease and [ __ ]
it how come you've never shared this
before I was happy that I found this
page fine two creases [ __ ] it
yeah I think there's like a fat lady
just in lingerie and with the phone
number and then it was like find a
crease and [ __ ] it
great sweaty so all the creases are
available oh that's that's true but this
is and I'm not about showing anybody
this is just like literally what is like
if I love everybody every anniversary
yeah I am NOT my pants aren't buttons
because my pants don't fit me okay I'm
like right here right now like okay it's
like this that was the first thing she
told us when she walked in hate it was I
drove all the way like that because I
don't want to UTI so anyways I have to
do it the UTI he needs to air-dry it
I've been using cardi B she was making
that joke with like fashion OVA she's
like uh unbutton these because I don't
want to UTI if you wear super tight
clothes is that true I can't breathe
what does your vagina can't yes
sure it's a medical statement truck well
there's also like girls that are more
sensitive exactly exactly yeah but like
what about chick around like nuns and
[ __ ] they get the UTIs a lot they like
each my shirt they're wearing like
woolly outfit so don't breathe that way
so hard in the wrong [ __ ] but now I know
let me pick no no it's a picture my see
and then when you see a nun well because
before I was picturing like something
like overall looking underwear whether
it like the bra and the panties one
piece yeah and it's just like thick
canvas but now it's I'm just like oh
[ __ ] she's naked underneath long
underwear like covered wagon underwear
yeah but probably like a huge furry bush
for sure you know oh it could be like
the American Horror Story nun where she
took off her Rogen it was like red
lingerie really sexy and [ __ ] super cute
that's probably more what the guys
well that's cuz the guy who did a Ryan
Murphy like is a gay he's amazing and
he's like you know he's like let's make
this [ __ ] sexy yeah he's awesome
he's so awesome I'm gonna turn on the
priest that's right yeah all I see what
time I was at LAX and then there's a
group full of nuns and then I went into
elevator and they all came in the
elevator too and then the door closed
but it was a really hot day and I was
scared to breathe why who's a hot day
and I just see like nun outfit I'm like
man this must be musky as [ __ ] and it
was like six or seven do you want to
inhale so I didn't want to inhale and
then have like a bad notion about nuts
so I just I don't know just myself my
friend yeah you don't have a negative
connotation I think I did the right
thing Jesus Olivia I did the right gift
I think they smell like rotten sense and
sage even on a summer day with all the
ways it could be hot yeah it could be
hot baby
oh okay well my favorite one was okay
there's literally so much so many of
them so there's gender specifics which
is like you know girls like playing like
very masculine like neckties suits you
know and guys are like Madonna [ __ ] some
guys were like IV lingerie underneath
her big lady like a little guy like not
fat but like like she's like six some
you told me about this and I've seen it
since did she will fit the guy up like
that it's crazy yeah it's crazy they
like to be crushed to and trampled on
and their small boy with the big chick
I'm sorry some small chick with the big
dude thing but that's kind of fairly
known and yeah the fuel a DS yeah and it
there's there's little people come in
yeah little girl ones or guy ones which
ones are both dead both oh but did
sometimes with each other sometimes with
non little people's it's like a thing my
favorite one though is the inflation
that's such a weird wasn't asleep fetish
oh my god that would be amazing
what is that more sleep so basically
like people get off they get aroused by
someone sleeping oh that's [ __ ] well
that's you yeah another part of it what
you just sleep there and someone's
getting off sometimes yeah if they don't
want to like you know actively
participate and what do you mean by
getting off like they're just jacking
off on the side yeah like I would get so
much [ __ ] to everything man yeah
that's really what it is it really is so
I don't know why I was like what just
shut off to you drinking out of a straw
you know what probably yeah they would
probably like DME to about it I'd get
some weird [ __ ] it's probably why I'm
just so open to him like oh yeah you
know haven't you guys gotten weird [ __ ]
they're my ideas right I don't shake my
dreams at all really only the people
that I already follow but like strangers
I don't check any of the teams that's
smart especially since you're married
and I know that now I had no idea what
the [ __ ] was happening so stress they'll
be like why are these people [ __ ]
kissing and touching each other I had no
clue I was like all I need a kid they
just got a house that's so awesome
no idea I had no idea like cult mm-hmm I
have no idea I'm still trying to figure
it out battling lupus oh well yeah I've
had issues which is why we're all back
baby
I try not to like pay attention to it
weird thing is now which I talked to my
general practitioner about it today
I'm starting and I'm like because I'm
not on any like recreational drugs
anymore
unfortunately um so what was your
recreation choice
mmm painkillers oh wow yeah which one be
careful that's the number one killer of
Caucasians I know it killed my cousin
actually it was really classy you got to
watch out and you're of that team I know
I got off of it but I don't look why do
white people like being so there's so
much it's there twice the drunk just
like yes it doesn't hit me the same way
hits you guys I think we're like what I
don't know okay anything crazy dude
anymore I'm gonna [ __ ] swig up a beer
and you got to pass out for four hours
now amen brother
I used to LA that's C mmm I think Asians
choice a drug is gambling gambling yeah
don't save money on everything as soon
as they go into a casino they [ __ ]
lose everything is that what it is yeah
you have to have one right for Southeast
Asian then it's heroin
yeah yeah yeah um so yeah I just kind of
um I have a they're not like full-blown
seizures anything but I like like lose
consciousness sometimes a little bit Wow
what causes that I have no idea yet I
have to go get an MRI again Carrie what
you're driving yeah I thought about that
this is the farthest I've ever driven I
was gonna do an uber but and it didn't
happen that bad like when I get
lightheaded before it happens you like
when you like don't eat and you feel
like you're about to pass out low blood
sugar yeah yeah it's that feeling but I
can't control it so maybe you matcha can
help from sip wait maybe matcha from sip
canal yeah for sure
of course sponsor is when I was when I
had kidney stones I was doing percocets
just to get through it and I can see how
people get the same team mm-hmm yeah
exactly well if they come down just
isn't worth it you know like you have to
figure and then my cousin passed away
socially what's the calm down feel like
you get angry I got so angry
really
I was like a [ __ ] attitude everything
you know it was awful
yeah and like you get sweaty and smelly
and your skin's all it's just not I
didn't have a comedown for some reason I
don't know why probably because you
we're taking it for a legitimate reason
oh that could be there you go yeah no
you know why cause you're not abusing
air right taking the I try to take it
taking it cuz you need it for payments
yeah okay that's happened to me I had my
eye like I had ICL which is like an eye
corrective surgery okay I think they
gave me vicodin or oxycontin or whatever
okay and then I felt floaty and it just
felt like pretty good and I'm like can't
believe people pop these things on the
regular because it didn't feel like
anything spike it in it just makes me
floaty yeah they say don't drive and I'm
like so what I'd still drove it maybe
because you're not depressed
maybe I depress it feels like so that
gets making him feel normal again
I feel pain in your bones and it's just
like that yeah like it's it's heavy yeah
life's pain I like to get like if I do
get [ __ ] up I always like to get
fogged up to where it's like I'm in a
different universe I'm talking to myself
[ __ ] up and if I don't achieve that
high I don't feel like I got high yeah I
wanna have someone else's brain in my
body yeah yeah I did I was I was yeah
yeah yeah I don't do anything anymore
why smoke like once every two months or
whatever yeah yeah you have to feel like
the older you get you have to pace
yourself like even me with wine I'm like
oh [ __ ] no [ __ ] she's like this is not
like the same the next day yeah the next
day I can feel it like I'm still brain
dead and [ __ ] and I can't think and I'm
like I got [ __ ] to do especially even if
I just stay up late one night and then I
wake up the next morning my body has
that like you know that hangover tired
it's gentle I for no reason yeah
I don't even drink yes I feel like I got
to stay home and watch TV and do nothing
but just like recover your girl just
came back for a big trip you know yeah
and it's just like smoked weed one night
that was it I know what is this one we
have to look forward to aging like what
the [ __ ] is this what did your
boyfriend's tell you I love you said
boyfriends cuz you know me so well
boyfriend's his life right now I know
y'all are boot up and your boot up and
over your boot up in your boot everybody
here I passed old mole time you said you
dated multiple guys that's why you were
booed up but now you're free I know
which is so weird I did everything in
Reverse but by the way I want to give a
big shout out to all of you awesome
amazing fans of just kidding you guys
are so sweet and so nice so thank you so
much really supportive yeah you guys are
really amazing and I wish I could date
all of you know all the dick pics are
gonna start running in you've got some
offers that's the best way to plug
yourself actually I know oh shut up
um I've been actively dating and I'm
learning how to [ __ ] do it right
which is what did you do differently
like before I got caught up on one
person constantly like I would go from
one person to one person to one person
and then never like explore and not like
go on at least five dates before I'm
like okay her so were you are like a
serial relationship person we're like
one and in the next person that gave you
attention you're just kind of like BAM
I'm with you he's the one you gotta read
this book by our friend Shannon Bertram
okay called the game of desire it's
[ __ ] top-notch yeah you can get it on
audio okay wait I can I have no
yeah it's really good it's all about
dating in the world and like getting to
know yourself your love language your
turn on triggers your apology language
so that you know exactly what you want
going into a relationship it's really
tight I just wanna announce my book as
well.all right-it how to how to [ __ ] a
robot with respect you know what that's
good where can I get it oh you can't
even oh yeah what are you plugging up
yeah I'm stop finishing it okay really
right time from when the the robots come
out right because I think a lot of you
are gonna be disrespecting on those
robots I think it's about loving your
robot eat wall having sex with them and
then a consensual way because it's a
person still well it's its own entity
laptops cuz that's a robot I want to
[ __ ] it well yeah if you treat your
laptop in a disrespectful way then yeah
it is it doesn't laugh that a couple of
times it there you go do you think
robots are like considered cheating cuz
there's like this big like hole on that
right now
oh that's my girlfriend probably I have
no doubt that in my future it'll be me
and my robot [ __ ] my wife beat me in
a robot I don't consider it cheating
like if I came home I saw her bent over
and there's a robot boning her on my
[ __ ] Arnold Schwarzenegger [ __ ]
terminator but then that means that you
consider like using toys as cheating
yeah they're like that if you come home
bargain this is part of topic of my book
if you come home bar which other angio
it's up there angio is making out with
that robot yeah that's gonna be a little
bit of a different story and then
telling her all her feelings and
emotions that she didn't tell you oh
yeah oh yeah that's emotional no it
really is a gay if you got horny and
then you wanted to [ __ ] the robot if you
a guy wanted to [ __ ] the robot is that
in your book Steve it's in my book you
so here's the thing if you're dominating
the robot it's almost like prison sex
you know it doesn't make you gay hmm
okay huh it's asserting your dominance
yeah exactly and I need a lottery you're
gonna [ __ ] my wife no I'm gonna [ __ ] you
yeah it's called taking the power back
No
as long as the robot doesn't come I'm
okay with that
right you could make them come or not
crazy
shut up isn't really they come they come
a lotion yeah no yeah it's good for your
skin my face does that protein and then
is all it has an enzyme you seem way too
knowledgeable about this I know I've
done my research
these are his books Jesus the deal for
pre-order right now your life's work get
ready for my book don't squeeze the
titty caressing
[Music]
[Music]